hi my name is ariana mendible and today
i'm going to be telling you about my
work in data different
data-driven decompositions for traveling
waves
so in general in science and engineering
there are spatiotemporal systems
that are high dimensional non-linear
chaotic
and have multiple scales of time and
space that we're interested in studying
and traditionally these systems tend to
have also traveling waves
this is a symmetry that just means any
coherent structure that moves throughout
space and time
so here we have an example of some
vertices that are traveling around in a
climate model
a shock wave behind an airplane and a
shock wave rotating around a detonation
engine
the typical way that we study these
systems because we don't have in general
governing equations that we can solve
analytically
is by using data-driven methods to
squish the data into smaller system
so that we can compute solutions to
predict and control these systems
the main way that we do this is through
proper orthogonal decomposition
so the types of data that we want to
consider are systems like this
where we have a function u that's of
space and time
uh space is x and time is t and u can be
any type of function
it can be here in the wave height or it
could be something like voltage or
pressure
or anything that we want to consider
the proper orthogonal decomposition
breaks this system down using space-time
separation of variables into modes in
space and time
and compresses the information into a
small number of modes
so we compute this using the singular
value decomposition which is efficient
and well studied and
used all over science and engineering
then when we compute the modes since the
energy is compressed into small number
of modes we can truncate them and use
only a few of them to represent the
system
fairly well the problem
is that svd or pod does not work with
traveling waves
so here i have a stationary wave that's
shown in pink and i have
the same soliton wave that is traveling
in space and time
when i go to decompose that wave into
one mode
we can see that the stationary wave is
very well represented and
almost all of the information is
captured as you can see here almost 100
whereas with the traveling wave one mode
reconstruction gives us a very poor
representation of the wave
and we also don't capture very much of
the energy so what happens when we
increase the number of modes here's two
modes
still does not do a great job 5 10
and we need almost 20 modes to be able
to represent this wave and capture all
of the information
so this is not a desirable outcome we
would like to be able to capture this
traveling wave in a very low number of
modes
so one approach that many people have
done to alleviate this problem
is to first shift the data into a
traveling wave frame so that those
traveling waves appear stationary
so our method that we've developed is
called unsupervised traveling wave
identification with shifting and
truncation
and we're going to use machine learning
to detect interpretable wave speeds so
that we can shift the data
into these moving coordinate frames
given by x minus ct
and create low dimensional models in the
moving quarter frames so that the waves
appear stationary
the way that i'm going to explain this
model is through an increasing
uh complexity so that it makes a little
bit more sense when i piece it all
together
so the simplest type of example i can
show is a single wave that's moving with
a constant speed
the first step that we can do to
decompose this is to find the wave peak
points
given by x and t that show the crest of
the wave moving across
we can make vectors x and t that
describe that
and then to find our linear wave speed c
we can solve for the constant in this
equation which is a simple backslash
to make it a little bit more complicated
what happens if we have a wave that has
a non-constant speed
so a way that we can do this is again
find the wave peak points x and t
and now we need to provide some kind of
information of what we're searching for
so providing some candidate model
library which contains any functions
that we want linear or non-linear
will allow us to use c to find the
coefficients of those functions
that correspond to the models that we've
input to find
a function that represents this wave
speed so then we can also solve this
using x minus ct which is solved by a
simple backslash
now the most complex version that i'm
going to go through is with multiple
waves of constant or non-constant speeds
so here i'll use this example of my
original data where i have
one constant wave and one non-constant
wave that are intersecting
we're going to again provide a model
library which will contain any potential
wave speed functions that we would like
to use
to represent either of these waves we
also have to use a variable
n that tells us the number of waves that
we're looking for so that we can
initialize our system properly
we've decided to use ridge detection to
find the peak points of these waves
which is a machine learning algorithm
that's used in image processing
and it's extremely fast and robust
and now that we have two different waves
we have to tell our algorithm
which models we want to fit to which
points so in order to do this we need to
separate those wave peak points into
multiple groups
so we can fit the right models so to do
this we're going to use spectral
clustering
which again is a machine learning
algorithm that is well studied and
robust
now comes the optimization formulation
so we still have our x minus ct written
in just slightly different way
so now we've augmented our t matrix to
include all of those speed functions
based on
the data that we have pulled out from
our waves
then we have our coefficient matrix
which now we've augmented to have
one for each wave so each row of the
coefficient matrix is going to
correspond to one of the waves that we
have up there
and each column corresponds to each
model that we have in our library
and again we also have x corresponding
to each of those waves
and now in order to fit only certain
points to certain
models we can use a weighting matrix
which masks those points
using a zero or a one weight to apply
one model to one specific wave group
so our optimization is great we have you
know all these different models that we
can fit to any of the waves that we want
but the problem is if we provide a full
library of say 100
different potential wave speed functions
and we have 100 points x and t
we are going to get a completely full
matrix that describes our wave perfectly
we can fit the wave speed exactly using
as many functions as we can
but the issue is that this isn't really
interpretable and doesn't have any
relevant physics that underlie it
so we're going to also add a sparsity
promoting term
sparsity in a matrix means that most of
the terms are zero and we only have a
few that are relevant
this can help us find parsimonious
models that we can really understand
and this kind of makes sense in real
physics because even highly complex
systems
such as the navier-stokes equations only
have a few relevant terms
and we know that these these equations
can describe
very complex dynamics with only a small
number of terms
so after we've found our functions x
minus ct that describe our wave speed we
can shift our original data
into coordinate frames that correspond
to each of those wave speeds
and now we can use our traditional
methods such as pod to decompose these
into low rank
shifted frames
so now that i've gone through my method
i'm going to show you one example on
simulated data
so here we have the nonlinear
schrodinger equation that i have
initialized with
an initial condition that gives us wave
speeds 2t minus 7
and negative 2t plus 7. the nonlinear
schrodinger equation exhibits this
breathing
phenomenon and it also has non-linear
interactions between the two waves that
are intersecting
so this is a pretty complex system that
is a good test case for our
method i've input a library of a few
polynomial speed functions
in order to fit to this known wave speed
so after i run my untwist method which
uses 2700 iterations
i have discovered these models for my
wave speeds which very closely match
what we know the wave speeds to be
the more interesting thing is when we do
pod we uncover
some very physically relevant modes so
here we have our right traveling mode in
this coordinate frame
and our left traveling mode in the other
coordinate frame now this shows
two individual waves with very little
noise for the other wave that has been
intersecting
and when we use a rank two
reconstruction of our data
we can uncover a physically realistic
model
that closely matches our original i also
want to contrast this with what happens
when you use pod
on the traditional coordinate frame as
is normally done
and we have our first two pod modes
shown here which
are not necessarily physically relevant
it doesn't show our two soliton waves
that
are contrasting each other and then
the reconstruction is also not faithful
to the original
so that's great we've been able to
validate our system on some simulated
data
but what we really want to be able to
use this method on is some real
laboratory data or data taken from
experiments
so the experimental data that we ended
up using to validate our method
was from a rotating detonation engine so
here we have an example
of a simulation of a rotating detonation
engine which has
this shock wave that travels around the
annulus of the chamber
so here is an example of a real rotating
detonation engine where we collected our
experimental data here at the university
of washington
thanks to james cook for our information
and we have
a video of the actual collected data so
as
the waves rotate around the chamber and
exhibit
bifurcations and non-linearities which
are not well understood
we can take this video looking down the
annulus of the chamber
and find the pixel intensity of these
different
wave fronts so after we have all of
these different video slices
stacked up we can take each one and
integrate the pixel intensity around the
annulus of the chamber
to get this vector of our wave
shape after we do that for each time
step we can get the data that looks like
this
where all of our waves are traveling
around periodically in x
so again here's our original data and
this is actually taken from that video
that i showed you so we know that there
are two waves when you zoom in really
close even though it's not
super clear on this top one so here are
our two waves
when we apply our untwist method we can
shift the data
into each of these traveling wave frames
with respect to the top wave or the
bottom wave
and this is what we obtain so now we
have a straightened wave which will be
amenable to pod
and we can find a mode that will
represent this shock wave well
and then the bottom shock wave well
so our first pod mode shows that we
actually capture the shock front
extremely well for both of these
examples and this has a physically
relevant meaning
we can also contrast this to the pod
mode that we get from the original data
in the laboratory coordinate frame
which does not have a good physical
meaning and doesn't really reveal any
dynamics that underlie the system
so aside from finding the wave shapes of
these different waves
another interesting avenue of research
is to find
the interaction between the waves and
find how those dynamics might be
showing up in different regimes so here
we have that same data that i just
showed you
and here's a representation of that by
just
computing the difference between the two
different wave fronts so this is just
the spatial difference between those uh
wave fronts
we can use dynamic mode decomposition to
find a linear data driven model i have
not
provided any functions or anything to
decompose this data and we can obtain an
interpretable equation
that gives a model for how those waves
are interacting which fits the data very
well
another interesting avenue is to find
models that might be non-linear to fit
the data
so here's a different example of our rde
data
where we have three waves that are
traveling around the annulus
and are interacting non-linearly so we
can tell that because we have this
peaky periodic behavior in our waves and
they seem to be accelerating and
decelerating with respect to one another
so we can pull out those positions just
like i did before and here we have uh
i'll call it y and z for our two
different wave positions
and we can fit a latka volterra equation
to find a model for this so the lack of
voltaire equations
are a good candidate because they
represent this peaky periodic behavior
very well
and is used typically to model predator
and prey interactions
the models that we compute can be seen
here and we can tell that these are good
models because they
even using only half the data to train
them maintain their frequency throughout
the data set
and do capture that peaky behavior very
well
so overall i've showed you the method
that i developed
to decompose traveling wave data using
only data and we can get out
interpretable speed models to tell the
interactions between these waves
the method that i developed is available
in this paper and then
the work that we've done on the rotating
detonation
and engine data is available in this
paper on archive
you can also find code for all this on
github and thank you for watching